[Music]
so much focus across the country
remaining right here on nevada and other
battleground
states as that razor thin race to 270
electoral votes
narrows good afternoon to you thank you
for joining us on 8 news now here at 4
30. i'm brian loftis and i'm kirstjen
joyce we're going to head right over
to our i-team's david charns david yeah
so let's show you that electoral math
right now behind me you see an updated
one to the one we just showed you on
screen it shows
arizona in the biden column we do think
that the lead there
we're not calling this race the
associated press has for
vice president biden but more and more
votes as these mail-in votes are counted
it is going in his favor up right now by
about 70 thousand votes so here's our
map and you can see why nevada is so
important
we have those six electoral votes it's
all joe biden would need to win this
election now we broke this down for you
showing you
biden's path to victory if he wins
arizona and wins nevada that's it
but another way he could win right now
is just taking pennsylvania
that's 20 electoral votes right there
almost call them electoral points
electoral votes and that race is is
getting close
as these mail-in votes again are getting
counted what about president trump well
it's a little more difficult
he's leading right now in north carolina
he's leading in georgia but not
as much as those votes are being counted
as well he could also take pennsylvania
and he could take
nevada as well so he has a couple more
states to get there
but again for joe biden all he needs
really are those two states
in our area another look at that map
there you see what's already all filled
in
in the states that we're looking at it's
this sort of backlog of these mail-in
ballots they all most of them accept
mail-in ballots for the next couple days
you know we do
until a tuesday north carolina they
accept them until tomorrow so the vote
well underway in this race not over not
called yet what were 48 hours after some
of these polls closed out on the east
coast brian
david thank you so much